hi i'm maya and i'm joyce and we're
hosting a watch party for amazon prime
video's
new series the wild and today we'll be
watching the pilot episode with you
the show is about a group of teenage
girls who get stranded on an island
oh my gosh i'm so happy that that's not
us i know sam
[Music]
joyce i heard that we have a special
guest yes
it's satin who was played by sophia ali
oh my god
welcome to the party hey guys excited to
be here
sophia tell us about this show so in
this episode that you're about to watch
it's a bunch of girls who don't know
each other getting on a plane
and then we crash land on an island
sophia could you tell us where the show
was filmed
so we can go there we filmed this show
in new zealand
we filmed part of it in piha beach and
it was so beautiful my first time in new
zealand
i would live there forever okay girl
please tell us about your
most favorite moment filming as a cast
we got really close
just like having these like really smart
empowered women around you all of the
time
but there was this small island called
waheki
right off of like the shore of auckland
and
it was a wine island and there was just
all of these wineries all over the place
and we would
take a ferry it was just like a
40-minute ferry from
auckland and just spend the day there
and get wine drunk together
so we're gonna check in with you at the
end of the episode but
we gotta go we gotta go get this party
started all right
bye enjoy we'll check in with you after
you watch the episode
these girls must be stuck on a deserted
island but we
are not so we'll be sharing our
reactions on screen but
you can share your reactions in the
comments below so let's
finally watch the episode
earlier this morning we made contact
with your parents
[Music]
we'll travel them here as quickly as
possible
and the quarantine order will be lifted
soon
not just for you but for all the victims
at which point you'll be free to see
each other
just to be clear our primary goal is to
conduct an investigation
there's a lot of haze surrounding your
circumstances that we just
want to clarify
and i cannot stress this enough but
this is just a conversation that's all
she looks like she's been through some
stuff this is my colleague
agent young he's going to be running
point on this
he's the investigator in charge brass
tax guy
if you will but me
um i'm here for you
leah to make sure you feel safe
as a trauma specialist that is my soul
and sacred duty
are you thirsty you like
that sometimes drink let's see
didn't know what you'd like so
we got a bit of a grab bag here
is anything calling your name
oh oh oh i used to drink these what was
that
who was that good great that's great
don't hesitate to ask for seconds
or thirds or anything at all
really after all you've been through we
want you to feel as
comfortable as possible what have the
others told you
nothing as of yet you're the first one
we've brought in
so then you don't know what i've been
through do you
you're just assuming trauma you're just
assuming it was a living hell
okay leah no one is assuming anything
sorry look i don't
i don't mean to say that what happened
wasn't traumatic
obviously it was traumatic
to end up where we did the middle of
nowhere
completely cut off from the lives we
left behind
that brings us to the real question
doesn't it
what was so great about the lives we
left behind
[Music]
because here's what i remember of all
that
i remember not being enough
i remember wanting to be more
i remember the dark moods the violent
moods
moods that nobody had any patience for
and then there was the brutal social
scene which some girls could just glide
through like
they belonged everywhere
and there you were just trying to belong
somewhere
[Music]
i remember the ridiculous expectations
they had for us
like we were supposed to be these golden
gods 24 7.
with blessings
i remember the responsibilities
heavy burdens meant for adults forced on
us before our time
[Music]
responsibilities that made you think
yeah
this is definitely my healthy
development right now
and don't get me started on the
impossible problem of sex
[Music]
if you were terrified of it which you
had every reason to be you'd be
deemed a frigid chastity [ __ ]
[Music]
but if you were somehow unafraid like if
it was just naturally your
thing oh there's our girl joyce yes
that's our boo
then god help you
the world is a dangerous place for a
sexually evolved girl
and on top of all that there was this
new feeling
this sick ugly feeling of
wanting to love and to be loved back
[Music]
which never ends well
[Music]
so if we're talking about what happened
out there
then yeah there was trauma
but being a teenage girl in normal as
america
that was the real living hell okay
that's a fire
scene to be a teenage girl in normal ass
america
that was a real living hell period put
that in a book and send it
a
hey
statement
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
tell us what you know about
the dawn of eve there i mean you just
would not the retreat
was my mother's idea she thought it
would be like
therapeutic did you have a chance to
look through the activities
you know they but maybe they were just
scared of me
my dad had started looking at me like i
was radioactive
private plane honey direct to the big
island if that doesn't boost you out of
your funk
i don't know what will please don't
refer to my emotional devastation
as a funk
leah i know you're recovering from some
kind of breakup
and i know you're not wild about this
trip but your father and i
we're kind of at a loss for how we can
help we're really trying here liam
[Applause]
hey hi
are you all right
hey what are you saying
is it pink is that your ringtone
hey hey stay with me jimnet
that was her name i found out later
and she was the only one who'd come
alone the rest of us came in pairs
there was tony and martha best friends
from minnesota
the texans dot and shelby
there was rachel from new york and her
sister nora
and fatten of all people from my school
but like i said none of this sunk in
until later
not faces not names not the ridiculous
welcome
video right now hundreds of girls just
like yourselves support charters
just like this one are on route to our
retreat in kona hawaii
for a long weekend of female-centric
learning and growth
the dawn of eve literally waits for no
man
i was somewhere else trying to disappear
into those
pages where it all began
do you know there is a vegan drum circle
on the south lawn
i mean seriously be a vegan or be
someone who does drum circles not both
everyone is just too interesting around
here i've got like
interesting fatigue is that why you hang
out with me
i'm so bland it gives you a chance to
recharge
i get it my hair is all one color
i'm a virgin that still drinks dairy
milk
[ __ ] i really am boring actually by
being the most normal poor person here
you've low-key turn the tables
you've become the freakiest freak of all
well
either you're a fattener the true basic
[ __ ]
why does she even go here you seriously
don't know
phantom is a cello virtuoso she's like a
shoeman at juilliard
you don't have to read that book you
know miss wolf only assigned it because
gallantus used to go here it's shameless
alumni promotion god have you read
chapter six yet
a 12-page description of the wallpaper
in a waiting room
yeah but i i think the waiting room was
like a metaphor though
for us stuck she felt
tell him yourself he's coming next week
some kind of
school-wide literary event
[Music]
so in the interest of bringing us all
together i'd like to propose a little
icebreaker
ooh like never have i ever uh that
game's a little much i know
so here's how it works one person says
something they've never done
and if you have done it you have to
drink alcohol uh
that game's a little intense like for
people who don't know each other real
well
so how about we just pair off pow wow
with your partner for a second then
afterwards you can introduce it to the
rest of us
this white girl said powwow so so it's
not her word you should be triggered
okay i'm not though why am i always
fighting your battles for you
i don't know because you like fighting
okay
guess i'll have to play matchmaker you
can come with me
right about here okay and it looks like
we'll need one little group of three
or you can just sit this one out
all right shelby and you are martha
martha it's a pleasure okay so let me
tell you a bit about me
okay i do real okay i do family i do
jesus i do pageants
and i'm doing this conference to offset
the pageants some
colleges might see them as retrograde
when it comes to female empowerment
has anyone ever told you have the most
drop dead gorgeous eyes
hey i've got a question about your shirt
i've got a few questions about your
cargo pants
yeah well i'm not a lesbian sorry to
disappoint i just like storage
um but i see shirts like yours
everywhere shirts that have
like a lot of attitude so what's your
question then
i guess just why are they saying um
because they're super cute and super
hilarious
i just think it's kind of funny you
wearing that to a feminist retreat
because your shirt
is literally telling women get out of
your face whatever i don't even get
feminism
i get called a girly girl like it's a
bad thing
so i'm double the amount of girl and
somehow that's not feminist
it's ridiculous hello
oh thank you so much this looks
delicious
thanks dude so you play basketball
yeah i used to i cut from the team from
sports for my conduct
this bit from another team kept fouling
me so i pissed in my hand and i throw it
at her
were you good hell yeah i was a beast on
the court
people waste their talent get on my
nerves if i missed even one meat based
off of some foolishness on my part i'd
never forgive myself
what are you doing i have an app that
turns my phone into a digital scale
also i have two pugs coco and jax
they're from the same litter but they're
like
so different so what kind of music do
you listen to i don't really know
everything i guess you know what's funny
i always say i'm into rap and hip hop
but the other day i was going through my
spotify history and guess who i listened
to most
pink it was like a wake-up call for me
honestly we should all be checking out
play count you can't hide from your play
count
and my play account says i like pink
who do you keep looking at my sister
has ever been listening to me at all
you're from san francisco you hate being
homeschooled do you work at your
family's restaurant
you collect erasers you have two pugs
named coco and jax and you're
existentially prepared to admit that you
like pink
no boys aren't really into me at least
none that you
know of oh i've got a pretty good lay of
the land it's
just none period well all you need is
one good one
andrew uh he is such a keeper for
anniversary he bought me an actual star
like in the sky and he named it after me
oh she'll be sorry
i i think you have cake in your teeth
would you excuse me thanks
[Music]
it's hard to talk about this part of
course
that must have been terrifying no
it was embarrassing
the thought did cross my mind knew this
could be my
final moment alive
how do you think i spent it oh no no
i didn't reach out for comfort here it
goes
i didn't cry i didn't shut everything
out
i didn't like carpe diem
or anything i didn't indulge
i took no measures to protect myself
i didn't pray for my mortal soul
[Music]
here's what i did i sat
in my [ __ ] love puddle
[Music]
and thought about a guy the world knows
him as the 2013 national book award
winner
but to me he'll only ever be the little
[ __ ] who sat at the back of my class
making paper clip chains and ignoring
every word i
said please welcome
jeffrey glass
i should say in hindsight that the the
paper clip chains that she's referring
to probably had more artistic merit than
uh
anything else i was turning in in her
class
anyway i thought that uh we would start
with the reading
carrie's wish was simple
for something to finally happen to her
something that would add color to the
bland desert of her life
and that's what it was hey i'm supposed
to take jeff back to his hotel after but
i am out of my goddamn eyeballs and ap
prep can you give him a lift
wait like jeffrey yeah
i will leave my brother i'll do it oh
god thanks
you they used to jump rope together
um
you are bleeding internally your heart
rate will be like shot i think you're
just
a little roughed up
[Applause]
grounding
[Music]
all right help me out with the timeline
here um about how long have you been out
there at that point
i don't know two three hours i'm just
trying to pin down when a crash occurred
i honestly
don't know from the crash until when you
spot at the shoreline you can't give me
a ballpark estimate
look i don't mean to be difficult
it's just that part at the beginning
it's all blur
and not just for me after the plane went
down
we all just blank in our memories
even the ones that came to on the island
oh no the chocolate cake oh and now she
throwing it up oh got it
boy
you gotta get up and move around right
you're in shock
they make me come i'm not supposed to be
here
who like your parents
well if it makes you feel any better
they're probably feeling pretty shitty
right now
like crushing guilt
you win well kind of not really
got a little bit of
[Music]
rachel are you okay
is this helping because if it is i
i won't stop for you
you think i'm doing this [ __ ] on purpose
no because it couldn't be motion
sickness
or the fact that we just woke up in a
nightmare right nora i was just asking
rachel
no you weren't you were treating me like
a child like you always do i mean that's
why we're here right it's true that's
not true
yes it is you got it in your head you
need to protect me and now we're here
when you ran your mouth off to mom and
dad what did you tell them nora
nor would you said i was worried about
you and maybe you needed a break
great great break right
[Music]
show me
hey
uh no it just needs a little tail
okay
sometimes you collide with a person and
you get this feeling that they might
become important to you
maybe it's from a look or an act of
kindness
[Music]
or maybe you just like the way your
world feels when they're in it
i'm really sorry by the way if uh this
is way out of your way
i would have called it uber or a lift or
whatever i just um
i am a person who has chosen not to
own a smartphone that's like a whole
thing okay a couple a few years ago i
just i lost my iphone
and so i had to revert to this old flip
phone and then i don't know i started
kind of
like the the luddite image that i was
projecting with it so much that i just
kind of stuck with it and
you know uh yes it is
admittedly an affectation um
so you want to listen to music uh yeah
you uh there's an aux cord in them in
that glove compartment oh [ __ ]
cds oh god don't those are
really old i there's no reflection
of who i am no it's no no judgment for
me trust me
and i'm dying to know what's on awesome
summer mix
i didn't name that in pink oh my god i
love pink
like i i feel like she's got like this
amazing
anarchic quality to her
yeah she's kind of eternal
your hotel's just right up here
oh man that was fast
i don't know if you're hungry but um if
you haven't eaten we could get some food
[Music]
oh
is there anybody else out there
thank you anybody i didn't see anybody
[Music]
[Music]
it's the last time you dropped on me i'm
fine seriously
shelby's been shelby's been amazing
you she's not wearing
she's not breathing too fast pumping
like double times no such thing it's too
fast only too slow
actually compressions can be too fast if
they're not deep enough dude slow down
boy he's up daddy you're going way too
fast okay hell if you're awesome experts
somebody else tap in
okay yeah you just have to go who knows
cpr
so it turned out everyone had a working
knowledge of cpr
that's weird isn't it that every single
one of us knew how
is that important for your for your
purposes or whatever
honestly it could be anything could be
relevant at this point which is why it's
crucial that you give us this full
picture account
of the flight of the others and
what you're doing on that plane to begin
with
[Music]
i feel like i should be asking you about
your book no i have to write an essay on
it
so i love your help
okay let me first ask you
uh what what'd you think of it
i loved it
i really did but at the end
like it got a little weird like it got a
little sentimental i think
i'm really sorry i didn't say that yeah
no it's
that's okay um
the truth is like sometimes at a certain
point
it feels like it's like impossible to
get honest feedback out of anybody
so uh i appreciate it thank you
very kind of you this is fun we should
do this again sometime
if that's not like child totally
unwelcome or whatever
she's in high school sir
can you even enter contacts into this
thing or is it just for selling drugs
oh you're being funny yeah oh sorry it
was a joke
i'm gonna let you behind the curtain a
little bit
if a girl really likes someone she won't
put their name in her phone
your crush is like sacred
you can't just file him in your contacts
between your cousin
and your chem lab partner that would
make him common
so you learn his number every contour
of every digit you carve those little
hieroglyphs on your heart
so you basically sleepwalk through the
rest of your life
waiting for dispatches from that magic
number
and then there's the pivotal text
it will probably come around midnight
and it will change everything
hmm
[Music]
you're awake yeah hi
you you made it yeah i did
[Music]
i'm sorry you have nothing to be sorry
for no you don't understand i'm
so sorry
[Music]
hey does anyone have a phone do you
think we would have said something if we
did i'm not even sure how many bars we'd
get out here just trying to think of
lifelines all right
they're gonna find us but we can't be
stupid we should make a big ass help
sign
like in that movie 28 days later what do
you think happened to the flight
attendant guy we should be looking
through suitcases finding phones you
can't just listen listen listen girl
it's the 21st century okay they will
find us but in the meantime we got to
keep track of our resources
eight cokes right now that's all we got
to drink just eight of these
hey but don't worry because if god
brought us to it god will bring us
through it you know the whole jesus
saves things that like literally it's
not gonna jetpack down and pull us out
of here no tony
okay the lord saves those who save
themselves which
is why i'm going to take a look in the
woods see if there's some fresh water
maybe you should come with hard pass
shelby here if you're really going
you got to take these you're so generous
you know what maybe i will go make sure
christ doesn't leave your ass in a
sinkhole guys what the hell dot
i'm sorry look i was saving her ass okay
it got real wet you honestly think sam
will dry it out
i read an article on the internet about
alternatives to rice in a bag sand was
mentioned
yeah well good enough for me
keep your ears peeled you'll hear moving
water before you see it
how come you know all this this may
surprise you but i'm not
just some delicate indoor princess okay
i go hunting with my dad all the time
so you do one hardcore thing that
doesn't mean you're not mostly an indoor
princess
how many pillows you have in your bed i
bet you've got one of those mega beds
with like 50 pillows
jermaid lupe she's got to keep taking
him off and putting him back on and it's
making her want to offer herself am i
right you know i'm right yeah well i've
also shut down a 10-point buck
snapped his neck to finish the job and
butchered him in the field all by
that myself us to contain multitudes
tony
turn around i have to be
plug your ears plug your ears or i'll
have to sing
that word is lamp into my feet
and it light into my path
oh you've got to be kidding me
it didn't happen consciously but i was
finally starting to notice the others
like martha how every creature
meant something to her
or nora how she always knew when you
were looking at her
and how her smile could mean a million
different
things the veil of obsession was
lifting the world i had narrowed down to
one was starting to repopulate
there's no better place to grow into
yourself
what does growing to yourself even mean
it
sounds gross like an ingrown hair
i didn't think it'd be so chilly i know
i'm not sure we're anywhere near hawaii
hey
this is yours right
but just like that the veil fell again
and he was all there was
[Music]
hi hi hi
hi
can i come in oh yeah yeah
this is so nice yeah it's
it's not bad you have three outlets over
there yeah i asked for one more and they
i said no hey happy belated birthday
thank you
[Music]
every girl has a vision for how she
wants to use it that's what we do
on the 18th on my 18 i went to the sonic
with no one to guide me
will you sign one for me some dream
about prom night
oh come on
[Music]
i'll do you one better
i'll annotate it for you with a nice
enough boyfriend maybe a bed
covered in rose petals
[Music]
i guess i thought it would be just like
the rest of my life just i'll
take a spaceship
unremarkable
maybe at a party or on an old
couch in somebody's damn basement lots
of condom
fumbling and apologies
if you had told me it would happen the
way it did
i would have told you to get the [ __ ]
out
of my
rainbow how good it is i like watching
you do ordinary things
makes you seem more real
[Music]
you are right like not you
like this is
real
[Music]
are you you're asking about
my feelings or
yes
oh my god yes
that makes 16. why do you think we're
only finding diets
anything with real sugar would sink
sugar being heavier than water
how long can the nine of us survive on
16 cokes
depends on the weather how hot it gets
a week and a half maybe
you're smart huh i just read a lot books
man can't get into them
try having an elite athlete as your
sibling
you do a lot of sitting on planes and
gyms in the stands
reading will happen but like your
phone's right there
and tv tv's so good
you know what they said like graphic
novels would be like the gateway drug to
books
and like i tried them apart from the
pictures they were pretty [ __ ]
ah [ __ ]
yeah of course the target would show up
it was heavy as [ __ ]
[Music]
i bet we'll get rich once they find us
swing for damages or whatever not that
your ass needs the money
keep listening for water
i'm so sick of looking at your ponytail
i feel like it thinks it's better than
me
then how about you go in front fine lord
in your mercy grant us water so that we
may drink
lord in your mercy are you just telling
me to shut up and listen different
when you pray god opens your senses
god's such a joke
don't you know he's just a brainwashing
tool designed to enslave the masses even
if you were just a
brainwashing tool did you ever think
maybe your brain could use a good
scrub
lord in your mercy grant us water so
that we may drink
lord in your mercy grant us
show me
[ __ ] i swear i didn't mean to it's all
right
yeah go ahead and go on back
i will too but you should get a head
start i'd really rather walk alone
look we found more diet coke of course
because you know sugar things and then
pants for you
so that your legs aren't cold not a bad
haul but
not great either but wait
there's more ah
you get a mini and you get a mini and
you gonna make hey you guys partying
without me
you're back did you find any water no
where's shelby
uh uh shelby yeah she's right there
your head oh that's fine then smack into
a tree if you can believe
yeah very silly of me
hey hey the phone's working
it's working oh my god listen we have to
be strategic
we only have one bar and almost zero
battery life left every second counts
may i just say i am ready to make the
call okay my aunt is a 9-1-1 operator
and
9-1-1 is out it doesn't work in every
country and we don't even know where we
are
so if we're closer to like japan 9-1-1
is useless japan's emergency number is
119. look
we only have to get in contact with one
person so i want you all to have someone
in mind
make sure you know their number and make
sure they love you enough to be waiting
by the phone right now
okay of course there's only one number
i knew by heart
hey i had to tell my parents you were an
uber
what are you doing here i thought the
san jose reading didn't end
are you okay september 5th
september 5th it's your birthday
when you turn 17.
oh my gosh
okay somebody she's 16.
somebody sent me oh a copy of your birth
certificate
be a certified mail and that means that
somebody knows wait
what watching or and that's like some
other level of
you gotta you have to get out of the car
just give me a second just
cart leah you have to explain you got to
get out of the car
you lied to me you're a child and you
lied to me
[Applause]
[Music]
you're not calling mom and dad they're
in morocco they probably don't even know
yet
calling coach no not no not her give me
the phone call
you're not going to answer you're just
going to call coach you can't call me no
[Music]
great job did you dial it right of
course i did do you mind
if i know dave and joe beth goodkin
they're pacing holes in the carpet right
now
[Music]
well that's that's just strange uh let
me real quick draw my boyfriend don't
bother andrew's probably dictate from
krista finley by now
oh okay go marty
it didn't work do you want to try it's
your phone
no i'm good here as much as i hate the
idea of calling those [ __ ]
your mom's always on the
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
it's ringing
[Music]
she's dead
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i don't get why we have to bury her
they're gonna come first soon then we'll
have to dig it right back up
it's only temporary just to keep the
animals away
shouldn't somebody say a few words
sounds like you're volunteering
i am an ordained youth minister
lord thank you
for the gift of jeanette we didn't know
real well but
she had a really bright spirit
and because she was made in your image
we can be sure that she was beautiful
amen amen amen
right right turn off the lights
we're gonna lose our minds tonight
what's the dealio
i think she liked pink yeah
she did
party crasher penny snatcher
call me up if you were
[Music]
don't get fancy just get dancing
why so serious
so always the blast if you are wrong
in all the right all my
underdogs we will never be
never be anything but
[Music]
come
loud
[Music]
i'm gonna swim out to the plane tomorrow
see if i can find anything it might be a
radio or call box or something
i'll come with you
how's your stuff so dry
my parents got me this
water-tight thousand dollar suitcase for
this trip
i thought it would like sweeten the deal
sorry
thank you hey let me get one
this is my rock bottom
so would it be crazy if i suggested a
little
icebreaker never have i ever
feels right
all right only if you go first
none of those [ __ ] lightweight
answers give us the reel
and never have i ever had vaginal
penetrative intercourse
so that's why your boyfriend's a cheat
he's not a cheat
glad i'm not the only one i would have
felt so stupid
get out of here it takes guts to save
yourself you know that
all right never have i
ever had a threesome
with two guys not two girls
on my period
i mean i'm not a freak
all right i got one
never have i ever throw my own piss at
someone
drink up tony with pride
so who'd you
i mean i always thought you were some
weird art proof
but that's how you drink
now you've had sex so who was it
him damn i had no idea you were such a
bad
[ __ ] well in your defense we've never
really talked before
so true story
so was it hot yeah
yeah but maybe in like a burning
building kind of way like it's probably
really
good i got out [ __ ]
that's poetic well at least your first
time guys face is on the back of a book
my first time was with a grocery bagger
at smart and final
god i loved him i loved him
you seem tired we can be done for the
day
the doctors really need you to rest
burning building
i'm sorry the burning building i hadn't
made it out it wasn't even close
there's some
there's something i
i haven't what told anyone this
before that night
in the dark
i was the only one who heard it
a ringing
buried where no one had thought to look
[Music]
i didn't know why she had kept it from
us
[Music]
i thought i had evolved
but the day it somehow made me stronger
just a little
just enough
what illusion
and she chose to call him and his stupid
flip phone
hello
jeff leah
are you calling me from an unknown
number so i'll pick up because if you
are that's really
that is really it has really you have to
stop calling me
don't text me do you understand that i
don't want to talk to you
anymore it's over
i'm sorry
so you never told the others you made
outside contact that night
what would i've said
that i was too strung out in the sound
of his voice to send up an sos did he
did he reach out
after the news broke diddy
did he call anyone to say he'd heard
from me
the authorities fielded a lot of calls
from a lot of worried parties didn't
care enough to do
anything
anything anything at all leah how about
you take a deep breath answer my
question it is the
only one i have it is
i just want to know if he tried for me
pathetic i know i expected more for me
too
remember this when you see the others
and you try to figure us out
there is no crazy
there's only damage
[Music]
and when you go looking for what caused
it don't waste your time on that
island
it'll get you nowhere
[Music]
i've been trying to reach you
which one jeanette
can we even proceed i mean without her
assistance on the ground i have another
operative have you located her
yeah she's still intact yeah tell me
exactly what happened
we're still piecing it together it looks
like there was some mishandling by the
transition team
and you cut her phone of course and
you're absolutely sure she's dead
this was about three hours ago
[Music]
in the group oh my
gosh those
[Music]
what a [ __ ] of a pretty face what a
waste that face that face what a waste
what a waste of a pretty face that face
what a waste that face that face
what a waste of a pretty face what a
waste
i'm scared but excited scared excited
okay let's get sophia back in here and
let's figure out what's going on
sofia oh my gosh that was a great first
episode can you please explain what that
crazy plot twist was i can't tell you
in depth what happens but it's
it's pretty crazy you gotta keep
watching to see so
did you have to keep this episode a
secret was it hard not telling
anybody about this yeah i mean we shot
this
a year ago i don't even know it's been a
while so
i obviously was naturally very excited
um about the specific content of the
show and wanting to share it with my
friends and family and
it was difficult to sort of just like
keep it at it's like
skeleton premise there is a decent
amount of action
in this episode did you guys have to
train for your roles
we did some water training we like put
in a tank
see how long we could hold our breath um
we you know in in some of the scenes
where we were fighting
we did rehearse those we choreographed
them but for the most part
no we there was a lot of times where we
were just thrown into these like
crazy scenarios and it really upped the
stakes
for us as actors you know it made it so
much more real because it was
could you describe your character for
the audience fatten
is so undoubtedly herself
she is promiscuous and girly
and it was cool for me to play this
character
she is very much into how she looks
how similar are you to your character
was it tough to play them was it easy
i relate to fatten in a way that any
teenage girl or someone who was a
teenage girl would relate to fatten
she struggles so much with her family
dynamic
especially coming from a muslim family
and i'm half
pakistani half white american
and my dad's family is muslim and
you know i was exposed to that but i did
have more of a
option with you know
what i was able to believe and fat and
didn't really have
that um and i think that she struggled a
lot with
that sort of control um and i think a
lot of teenagers do
you know um we question our parents and
then they tell us what to do and we
question them more because we just want
independence
so what's in store for the rest of the
season why should the audience binge
the wilds if you're into suspense
mystery
love um
anything watch the show you can binge
watch it
on amazon prime video now bye
bye all right everyone cozy on up i've
got my urban outfitters stargazer
blanket
and i have my heated slippers urban
outfitters has
everything you need to cozy up to watch
the wilds
this december they even have an
exclusive vinyl that features the title
track of the wilds
thank you so much for joining our watch
party we had so much fun and hope you
enjoyed the episode as much as we did so
if you guys want to watch more of the
wilds
subscribe to amazon prime video where
you can watch
every single episode if you're not
already a member you can activate a free
trial to watch the wilds and
other amazing original shows and movies